[Musique]
info ou intox avec antoine fenaux ce
soir antoine bonsoir on va prendre la
direction avec vous de la république
démocratique du congo avec une un fox
autour de l'art ou est absolument clair
une un peu de contexte d'abord avant de
vous présenter c'est un fox pour
comprendre un peu d'où elle vient la
belgique on l'a souvent évoquée sur
cette antenne vous le savez entrepris
une politique un peu de mea culpa on
peut le dire sur c'est au tour de sa
présence coloniale en rdc politique
illustrée notamment par la visite du roi
philippe dans le pays avec des actes
concrets notamment dans le domaine de
l'art lors de sa visite vous allez le
voir le souverain avait annoncé la
restitution d'un masque à la république
démocratique du congo et là vous voyez
sur cette photo il avait d'ailleurs
présenté à l'époque au président félix
tshisekedi et c'est de cette restitution
que par notre un fox elle est basée sur
ce montage photos que vous apercevez
derrière moi donc notre masque avec la
photo que je viens de vous montrer un
instant à droite et une autre photo à
gauche d'un autre masse cette fois en
noir et blanc la légende infirme qu'il
s'agit d'une photo d'archivés de 1939 et
il s'agirait d'une effectivement du même
masque l'internaute le hic vous voyez
ici s'interroge sur l'identité de ce
masque est sous-entendu il s'agirait
d'un faut restituer par la belgique
sous-entendu le la rdc aurait été flouée
la montage a également beaucoup circulé
sur cette même forme sur facebook
également l'internaute là vous voyez là
on est complètement convaincu la
belgique 1 jouent avec nos esprits nous
ont remis une copie certains sont même
allés plus loin ce congolais vous
apercevez a même fait une longue vidéo
youtube pour dénoncer la différence
entre ces deux masques et ce faux
supposé autour de cette différence alors
qu'en est il alors copie ou pas de copie
pour ce masque et bien c'est toute la
question il pourrait répondre il faut
savoir d'ailleurs d'où vient ce masque
il s'agit d'un masque dit qu à koungou
il appartenait au musée royal de
belgique ce masque était nous apprend à
la bbc utilisé lors des cérémonies de
guérison par la communauté soukous à
noter que ce marche a été acheté par un
marchand d'art il ya exactement soixante
dix ans notre masque figurant sur la
photo on aurait elle donc je vous ai
montré un petit peu plus tôt est lui
aussi un masque cas congo on les
reconnaît j'en ai choisi quelques
exemples qu'on peut facilement retrouver
sur internet vous le voyez avec ses
joues proéminente ces grandes pommette
et ce très long et que vous apercevez
sur play plusieurs exemples ici c'est
des caractéristiques un illustrait la
virilité lors des cérémonies
traditionnelles le musée royal de
belgique lui vous le voyez et des îles
propose effectivement dans son
inventaire que j'ai retrouvé ici pour
vous en ligne plusieurs une collection
complète de différents types de masques
traditionnels certains viennent de
république démocratique du congo
effectivement et d'autre de d'autres
pays d'afrique mais j'ai parcouru cet
inventaire est impossible donc de
retrouver ce masque que vous avez pu
apercevoir sur la photo en noir et blanc
alors ici info intox qu'on a un peu têtu
pour en avoir le coeur net et bien on a
appelé le conservateur du musée en
charge des collections ethnographiques
il s'appelle julien volper on peut
facilement retrouver son nom sur le site
du musée et nous a donné de précieux
détails clairs et donc le fin mot de
l'histoire et bien ce conservateur c'est
lui qui nous la donne et vous vous en
doutez ce masque sur la photo en noir et
blanc est bien authentique et il n'a
mais il n'appartient pas au musée juin
voltaire nous a d'ailleurs transmis
cette photo qui appartient au musée
royal de belgique et vous avez que vous
avez pu apercevoir au début de mon
intervention lui en tout cas il est gâté
catégorie t-il dit que ce masque
n'appartient pas du tout à la collection
du musée qui ne fait d'ailleurs partie
d'aucune collections privées ou
publiques selon lui ce match n'a jamais
été collectés sous-entendu récupérer
pour être exposé dans une quelconque
musée pas de copie donc vous l'avez
compris c'est juste un masque différents
mais authentique l'un fox elle est là un
but est bien c'est de discréditer
l'opération belge de restitution à noter
pour terminer là dessus que cette
opération de restitution justement des
oeuvres d'art belge à la république
démocratique du congo du congo dit
qu'une première d'une longue liste en
février dernier vous l'apercevez la
belgique a transmis aux piles inventaire
complet de ce patrimoine en sa
possession de ses oeuvres d'art pour
procéder à des demandes de restitution
de makam 84000 en catalogue est à noter
que 35 40 mille d'entre elles pourraient
être concernés par ces restitutions
merci beaucoup antoine renaud on peut
retrouver votre chronique sur notre site
internet
www.francebillet.com on se retrouve dans
quelques instants à 22h30 heure de paris
pour un nouveau journal paraît direct
continue rester avec nous
[Musique]
bon